The Joe Rogan Experience no no I'm sorry
sir I'm gonna hold that character for
three months well you know I did Joker
and I worked with Joaquin Phoenix same
thing I was in the in the room with him
for five days and
you know when when he came I think to
set he was a hundred and when he when he
was walking around 180 pounds or
something and I think Todd Phillip said
something like I think the character
should be kind of skinny just kind of
said it you know casually like I think
and Joaquin I think showed up at 124
pounds and then they were like let's
just give you uh this guy's got inhuman
discipline they go let's give you a
nutritionist and everything else and he
said no no it's okay he just ate an
apple and smoked cigarettes and when we
were on set he never looked at you
and he never looked at you in one at one
point um I went like this I had a scene
if you blink I'm out of it but I had a
bunch of lines that didn't make it but I
go like this I go what'd you do take a
gun and blow your head off and I
mimicked it and I put it in my mouth
like that and when I did that
I I fell back he I did that twice on the
second time he fell straight back
he fell straight back and landed
like it just he would just improvise and
do crazy [__] where you didn't know if
he was going to even hurt himself
remember when he punches the clock
that's not in the script
he just punched that clock off the wall
and Todd thought he broke his hand that
was not on the script I I saw I when I
saw you know the bus team where he can't
stop laughing I saw them shooting that
when I got the set I swear to God I saw
him walking and I I knew he was going to
win an Oscar it was that good and I
looked at Todd and I go holy [__] he
goes you have no idea dude it was like
when I saw the fighter Christian Bale
and the fighter remember that opening
scene I went oh you're gonna win an
Oscar at this I I don't know you could
see it you're like you're a crack addict
and you're about you're an ex-boxer you
see one frame and you go well this is
something different is happening here it
was the same thing with him but I
watched him for I think it was four or
five days I was there and uh I've never
seen somebody be able to hold that
concentration and that kind of character
for that long I was like I could never
do that I don't want to do that that's
not fun to be around that was a spooky
movie because I was like this is like
too close to reality Masterpiece and
then right after that you have the BLM
riots and the covered riots and all that
stuff happened afterwards I know have
you met Todd Phillips who writes and
directs those movies no you need to meet
him I loved me he's one of my favorite
people I love The Hangover he's such a
special dude you should have him on the
podcast I think you'd love him man he
grew up like he grew up like in a
one-bedroom apartment with his mom in
New York and and I think he's just a
[__] genius he gave me notes on a
script I wrote once and I was like oh
that's why you're that's why you're a
genius isn't it funny that we like
people better if they grew up in one
with chaos I feel like he grew up in a
mansion in Park City
Park City Utah just overlooking the
slopes yeah yeah